[Musik]
corona kontrolle mit streifenwagen und
durchdrehenden reifen dass hier das war
in dieser woche die jagd auf einen mann
in hamburg der keine maske getragen
hatte und das hier das ist der minister
der immer wieder mahnt wir sollen
verzichten auf geselligkeit aber er
selbst hat sich zum geselligen dinner
verabredet kurz nachdem er diese mahnung
ausgesprochen hat das alles trägt bei
zusätzlich zu corona frust zu locker und
frust in diesem land wie geht's endlich
raus aus dem locker und das ist die
entscheidende frage die wir gleich dem
vizekanzler stellen werden die richtigen
fragen mit olaf scholz jetzt bei bild
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen an den vizekanzler
und bundesfinanzminister hierbei bild
olaf scholz schönen guten abend
der hessische ministerpräsident volker
bouffier sagt die leute an die schnauze
voll sie auch ich glaube da geht es auf
die eine oder andere weise jedem so dass
wir das gefühl hätten haben das könnte
jetzt mal alles vorbei sein
noch ist es nicht vorbei aber es gibt ja
auch hoffnung denn mit dem
fortschreitenden im fernen mit den neuen
möglichkeiten des testens können wir
doch sagen wir werden ganz sicherlich im
sommer im biergarten sitzen und die
nächste fußball saison wird auch
ziemlich normal stattfinden
bis dahin scheint im moment noch ein
weiter weg zu sein und corona locker und
frust und schnauze voll ist auch
deswegen so weil einerseits eben der
locker und schon so lange dauert und man
gleichzeitig das gefühl hat dass der
staat dort unverhältnismäßig teilweise
durch greift wo corona regel verstöße
geahndet werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jagdszenen in lockerer und zeigen
polizeieinsatz nicht etwa gegen einen
schwerverbrecher sondern einen
jugendlichen ohne maske szenen die
undenkbar schienen in kronau deutschland
aber alltag werden dennoch so deckt die
polizei neuerdings coroner regelverstöße
auf mit hubschraubern die spaziergänger
observieren mit hochleistungs kameras
der korona überwachungsstaat auch beim
joggen an hamburgs als der neuerdings
nur noch mit maske beamte im einsatz
gegen die die frische luft suchen
bewegung die dem lockdown für kurze zeit
entfliehen wollen
ihnen drohen geldstrafen jagd auf kroner
regelbrecher mit streifenwagen und
durchdrehen
der korona kontroll war in diesen tagen
erlebt er einen neuen traurigen
höhepunkt
jagdszenen auf corinna regelbrecher dass
es ihre stadt
herr scholz was fällt ihnen zu solchen
jagd sehen ein
ich glaube dass die polizei insgesamt
doch eine sehr sehr schwere arbeit hat
und die dann für die regeln
durchzusetzen deshalb finde ich das
immer sehr bequem wenn einige im
fernseher sagen das hätte man ja
vielleicht anders machen können da war
ich nicht dabei
aber ich glaube schon dass es die
aufgabe ist immer angemessen vorzugehen
und gleichzeitig will ich sagen die
regeln müssen eingehalten werden da
können wir nicht die polizei mit
beauftragen das durchzusetzen und dann
uns hinterher beschweren wenn sie es tut
das stimmt aber sind solche szenen nicht
ausdruck von der unverhältnismässigkeit
und auch von der allgemeinen stimmung im
moment im land ja dass man das gefühl
hat mensch also da wird jetzt über die
maßen und unverhältnismäßig genau
hingeschaut und durchgegriffen noch mal
wenn wir der polizei in auftrag geben
dann dürfen wir nicht so tun als ob wir
ihnen nicht erteilt hätten
und umgekehrt will ich gerne sagen es
ist die grundregel jedes polizisten
jeder polizisten immer verhältnismäßig
im einsatz zu bleiben und das muss man
dann ja auch fall für fall betrachten
nur das will ich so sagen das mache ich
hier nicht vom fernseher gucken wir
bilder aus vom verband sucht ich weiß
alles über diesen einsatz
das video dort aus hamburg hat deswegen
so emotionalisiert auch weil viele
moment wahrnehmen dass der staat in
anderen bereichen nicht so funktioniert
wie sie es gehofft wie sie es erwartet
haben dass der staat ist nämlich nicht
schafft alten und pflegeheime so zu
schützen wie es sein müsste dass der
staat es nicht schafft den impfstoff zu
bestellen und zu verteilen so wie man
das erwartet dass der staat ist auch
nicht schafft die tests so schnell zu
besorgen wie man das erwartet der
erwarten durfte vom staat und dann
werden corona regelbrecher so verfolgt
zumindest manchmal
auf alle fälle haben sie recht da gibt
es einen zusammenhang und deshalb ist es
ja sehr wichtig gewesen dass wir am
anfang des jahres an diese klare
diskussion darüber hatten
ob man nicht hätte mehr impfstoff
bestellen können ich habe zu der zeit
das sehr klar ausgesprochen und
festgestellt dass einige fanden darüber
dürfte man gar nicht reden jetzt gibt's
ja große
übereinstimmung mit dieser damaligen
frage das hätte anders laufen müssen
trotzdem geht es dann jetzt natürlich
darum nach vorne zu gucken und zu sehen
wie kriegt man das besser hin wir haben
jetzt als bundesregierung zum beispiel
einen sonderbeauftragten bestellt der
auch bei der impfstoffproduktion hilft
ich stimme ihnen zu dass mit dem testen
muss jetzt genutzt werden da müssen wir
alle kapazitäten einsetzen um daraus
auch eine bessere eröffnungspartie 'we
zu entwickeln mir geht's nochmal kurz
herr scholz um das maß ja dass man auf
der einen stelle ganz besonders hart ist
wir kennen das ja seit wochen seit
monaten mittlerweile von corona
kontrollen und auch teilweise hohen
bußgeldern die verhängt werden und dann
gleichzeitig lässt man es an vielen
stellen eben schleifen oder funktioniert
der staat eben nicht mit der nötigen
konsequenz und an der stelle wäre es
möglicherweise viel viel wichtiger ich
bin jedenfalls für ein staat der mit
aller konsequenz seine dinge vorantreibt
ob das nun die impfstoffproduktion ob
das das testen ist oder ob das nachher
das impfen ist auch da
es ist meine feste überzeugung dass wir
sehr sehr viel arbeit da reinstecken
müssen das uns nicht passiert dass wir
eines tages immer noch nicht genug
impfstoff für alle haben aber viel mehr
als dann jede woche verimpft wird denn
das werden ja in wenigen wochen schon
millionen im funk pro woche sein
ich will noch mal ein letztes mal bei
dieser szene bleiben bei der
verhältnismäßigkeit das heißt selbst
wenn experten sagen
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass man sich
überhaupt an frischer luft anstieg die
ist verdammt gering das heißt sie finden
es trotzdem richtig weil sie sagen das
wird mit konsequenz geahndet dass man
überhaupt mit dem streifenwagen da in
den park reinfährt und diejenigen
rausholt die eben sich nicht
regelkonform verhalten
ich habe da eine sehr grundsätzliche
haltung die habe ich ihn eben schon
gesagt ich finde dass wir sehr dankbar
sein dürfen für die schwere arbeit die
polizei und deutschland leistet und
deshalb bin ich nicht einer von denen
die gewissermaßen von der ferne kluge
ratschläge gibt dann muss man sich auf
den jeden fall gegen einzelfall
einlassen nochmal es gehört zur polizei
einsatztaktik dazu dass sie immer
verhältnismäßig bleibt aber wir sind es
als bürgern und bürger die aufträge
erteilen und deshalb müssen wir auch
dazu stehen dass wir sie erteilt mit dem
streifenwagen in den park und dann
kennen wir hier bilder aus berlin aus
dem görlitzer park wo am hellichten tag
halt einfach die drogen vertickt werden
und man sitzt daneben im park und denkt
immer entsprechen können dann kommen die
wenn man kommen die denn und er kommt
aber niemand deshalb sind wir beide ja
wahrscheinlich gemeinsam der überzeugung
dass muss immer gut funktionieren und
dann gehören die knöllchen eben wie
heute zum beispiel in düsseldorf auch
dazu für diejenigen die beim
spazierengehen einfach mal stehen
bleiben weil das ist halt in lockdown
zeiten so ich finde wer regeln erlässt
darf hinterher nicht so tun als hätte er
sie nicht erlassen da gibt es überall
entsprechende regelung die vor ort
gemacht worden sind und diejenigen die
man zuletzt beschimpfen darf das ist die
polizei wir wollen alle raus aus dem
lokal und die ungeduld der frust wird
immer größer jetzt gerade den hessischen
ministerpräsidenten schon zitiert mit
seinem schnauze voll zitat am mittwoch
kommen sie nun wieder zusammen sie
ministerpräsidenten finanzminister
wirtschaftsminister und und und mit der
kanzlerin wird das ein lockerungs gipfel
wir reden über öffnungs perspektiven das
ist fest vereinbart und deshalb kann ich
ihnen berichten dass jeden tag
gegenwärtig überall gespräche kleine
große konferenzen stattfinden um das
gespräch am mittwoch vorzubereiten
innerhalb der bundesrätlichen weitere
neuigkeit und das würde glaube ich die
die mehrheit der deutschen auch nicht
wahnsinnig befriedigen wir ein
sensorisches soll genau das wird jetzt
geredet um am dritten eine entscheidung
zu treffen
und da bestehe ich auch drauf also es
kann nicht sein dass wir zusammenkommen
und dann kommt nichts bei raus sie
besteht noch immer eine auf öffnung ich
bestehe darauf dass wir entscheidungen
treffen und eine eröffnungs perspektive
konkret formulieren und das ist ja auch
schon von vielen gesagt worden aber auch
ein konsens über den ich ihnen gerne
berichten kann dass wir die
möglichkeiten des impfens aktiv für eine
eröffnungs strategie des testens aktiv
für eine öffnung strategie mit verwenden
worden das heißt wenn getestet in dem
moment wo flächendeckend getestet werden
kann zum beispiel vor geschäften zum
beispiel vor restaurants kann da
geöffnet werden es wird nicht alles auf
einmal gehen ich glaube das ist ein
guter grundsatz den wir alle miteinander
in unserem leben gelernt haben und das
gilt dann auch für so eine schwierige
herausforderung wie die bekämpfung der
korona pandemie aber es muss einen
schritt für schritt folge geben die
jeder nachvollziehen kann
und dann muss man das testen dort
einsetzen wo es besonders wirksames wir
brauchen auch mehr tests zum beispiel in
den unternehmen ich möchte dass die
unternehmen ihre mitarbeiter und
weiter testen wo wir zu viele haben ich
möchte dass wir in schulen und kitas
diese möglichkeiten intensiv einsetzen
es muss einen bestimmten zugang geben
dazu dass man tests auch als bürger
einfach irgendwo und am testzentrum
bekommen kann
da haben wir ja auch vor dass wir diesen
weg jedenfalls für das testzentrum auch
gebührenfrei gestalten und das muss dann
eine folge haben für das was an öffnungs
schritten möglich das heißt das testen
das ist absolut im fokus und das ist
jetzt auch kurzfristig einen weg ein
langsamer weg heraus aus dem loch daun
es ist ein teil des weges raus aus dem
block down und ich finde das können wir
uns doch alle gemeinsam ziemlich gut
erklären es gibt die die
rahmenbedingungen das impfen schreitet
fort und umso mehr bürgerinnen und
bürger geimpft sind umso mehr öffnung
schritte können wir auch wagen noch
nicht weil wir ja erst mal aus gutem
grund gesagt haben wir impfen die
älteren diejenigen die vielleicht gar
nicht so viele kontakte haben aber die
geschützt werden müssen weil sie sonst
sofort nicht nur mit gesundheit und
leben bedroht sind wenn sie infiziert
sind und das was wir dann als nächstes
jahr machen können ist viel mehr
personen impfen die aktiv im leben
stehen vielen begegnen und deshalb auch
das virus übertragen können und um so
mehr wird davon geimpft haben umso
besser kommen wir auch raus und dann
muss man eben gucken was funktioniert
muss das auch ganz technisch besprechen
wie will man das eigentlich machen ich
glaube es gibt zu viele halbgare
ankündigungen wohl jemand sagt so könnte
man das doch machen dann fragt man
dreimal nach und dann ging das gar nicht
so genau man darf jetzt einmal die
antwort aber gibt es die am mittwoch
also ja sie bei den test weiß ich nach
der sitzung am mittwoch vor ostern
beispielsweise werde ich an ab demo dem
tag mit einem negativen tests im laden
rein kommen ich finde dass man anhand
der entscheidung die mittwoch getroffen
werden eine klare maßgabe hat nochmal
genau versteht was wann wie passiert
nochmal zum testen zielen sie auf vor
ostern also ist das eine eröffnungs
perspektive die irgendwo am
sankt-nimmerleins-tag liegt oder ist das
ein eröffnungs perspektive vor ostern
sankt nimmerlein wäre völlig falsch ich
habe ja eben schon gesagt dass ich so
das gefühl
man muss jetzt auch mal die hoffnung
vermitteln die berechtigte dass wir im
sommer wieder im biergarten sitzen
können und dann müssen wir jetzt die
schritte dazwischen beschreiben wann
geht was und ob das vor oder nach ostern
ist eine frage über die jetzt sehr
sorgfältig geredet wird da will ich auch
nicht vorgreifen weil ich nämlich nicht
zu den leuten gehören die es besser
finden sie macht man eine ankündigung
als dass das was sie malen hinterher
auch stimmt sie mein herr sparen damit
mit dem alten job
da gibt es so viele da muss man sich
jetzt nicht nur herr sparen das konkrete
angefordert angekündigt dass es ab
morgen im ich hab montag über all diese
tests gibt und die test gibt es aber
nicht überall
wir haben verabredet dass wir eine
strategie aus einem guss entwickeln
wollen und das wird am mittwoch dann
zusammengeführt und dazu gehören dann
die öffnungs schritte die reihenfolge
was geht bieten und da gehört das testen
passend dazu ist ja ganz wichtig dass
man jetzt auf diese tests cook das ist
ja schon mal eine wichtige nachricht das
würde möglicherweise einen davon lösen
können auf den incidents wert so streng
zu gucken ist das so bisher hat man auf
die 50 geguckt dann seit der letzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz auch noch
auf die 35 und jetzt sagt man das ist
gar nicht mehr die einzig seligmachende
einzig seligmachende weg sondern in dem
moment wo die tests da sind da können
wir öffnen
wie gesagt wir können öffnungs schritte
wir reiben die nacheinander erfolgen
nicht alles auf einmal nicht damit dass
jetzt völlig verändern aber ganz klar
die tests sind eine zusätzliche neue
möglichkeit weil wir sie jetzt in großem
umfang verfügbar haben können wir müssen
natürlich genau zählen haben wir auch
genug für all das was wir jemals
beschließen das muss mit den unternehmen
zusammen rückgekoppelt werden damit wir
auch da keine falschen versprechungen
machen und falsche hoffnungen erwecken
aber ja wenn man testet hat man mehr
spielräume und die muss man genau
beschreiben was uns nicht passieren darf
ist dass wir jetzt irgendwas öffnen und
dann kurze zeit später wieder zu machen
wenn ganz deutschland weil wir uns
vertan haben und die ansteckungsraten
dramatisch nach oben ihn aber wenn wir
sie irgendwie stabilisieren können und
mit hilfe von tests und mithilfe an des
fortschreitenden impfens in die lage
kommen dass wir eine bessere situation
haben dann haben wir mehr möglichkeit
die frustration entsteht ja auch darauf
dass die diese werte gemeinsam mit
den anderen ministerpräsidenten und
regierungsmitgliedern festgelegt haben
die 50 und die 35 und man sieht menschen
kommen da gar nicht hin wir kommen da
gar nicht runter das heißt das könnte
erweitert werden man guckt
möglicherweise auf die 70 auf die 75 und
sagt okay wenn das der wert ist dann
eine helfende der erste entscheidende
sind war die richtung also wenn wir
verhindern können dass die
ansteckungsraten wieder plötzlich
dramatisch nach oben gehen dann haben
wir viel erreicht und genau
herauszufinden wie wir das hinkriegen
können das ist die aufgabe die jetzt vor
allem steht und über die hier zu viel
beraten wird wo alle sich rat holen von
expertinnen und experten selber das
einschätzen ganz viele den
taschenrechnern nehmen und gucken wie
viele tests sind das überhaupt kann man
das organisieren gibt es überhaupt
genügend möglichkeiten dazu wie kommen
die alle schnell genug dahin wo wir sie
dann einsetzen wollen das sind ja alles
fragen die in einem gut geführten staat
miteinander beantwortet werden will ich
klar ich frage auch nicht um sie weiter
zu quälen will ich habe verstanden dass
es neulich durch richtige ergebnis
gehirn aber ich möchte verstehen was sie
damit meint
und wenn sie sagen es hängt jetzt an den
test dann hängt es so habe ich es
verstanden nicht mehr so streng an dem
incidents wert das ist nichts weniger
als ein strategiewechsel
wir müssen auf die inzidenz werte
schauen und haben sie ja auch im gesetz
festgelegten der der deutschstunde in
dem gesetz das der deutsche bundestag
auch noch mal speziell angepasst hat für
die jetzige pandemien und deshalb ist es
ganz ganz wichtig dass wir das nicht aus
dem auge verlieren aber wir haben mit
viel mehr tests auf eine etwas größere
bandbreite und die wollen wir auch
nutzen weil wir natürlich nicht aus
duffy oder aus irgendwie verbohrtheit
jetzt diese beschränkung veranlasst
haben sondern zum schutz der gesundheit
der bürgerinnen und bürger und des
lebens viele größere bandbreite beim
incidents wert durch die tests
das ist das was wir alle für möglich
halten wenn ich das richtig verstehe aus
den vielen gesprächen die ich geführt
habe
und jetzt muss man das richtige maß
finden das wäre ja eine echte öffnungs
perspektive weil wie gesagt das gefühl
ist im land wir gucken jeden tag darauf
diesen blöden inzidenz wert und sehen es
geht einfach nicht mehr weiter runter
auch möglicherweise weil
zeigen dass plötzlich alles nach oben
geht dann müssen wir auch daraus
konsequenzen ziehen solange wir nicht
durch sind mit dem impfen aber wie
gesagt alles hat jetzt ja eine gute
richtung und wir müssen jetzt
gewissermaßen das erreichte nicht
verspielen und das mögliche auch für
alle nutzbar machen wo gucken sie dazu
erst drauf auf welche branche wenn wir
über testungen sprechen gucken wir
zuerst auf den einzelhandel man musste
sich immer ganz konkret anschauen wo
geht das überhaupt gerade auch weil es
ein massengeschäft
da bin ich noch nicht ganz sicher was
jeweils die richtige vorgehensweise ist
weil natürlich man sich vorstellen kann
und muss jetzt abstrakt zu sagen wie
einfach das ist bei einem museumsbesuch
einen selbsttest davor zu schalten
aber das ist eben wenn tausende durch
eine einkaufsstraße gehen und in
geschäfte strömen eine ganz andere
nummer
und deshalb muss das noch mal sehr
sorgfältig überlegt werden wo das genau
auch sinnhaftes das finde ich schon dazu
sagen und darüber wird auch jetzt
diskutiert lassen sie uns das einmal
diskutieren mit einer runde auch von
praktiker nämlich mit der kaufhaus
chefin tatjana steinbrenner mit der
kosmetik deren kurse aus pinneberg und
mit niklas zötler der geschäftsführer
inhaber ist einer ganz alten
traditionellen privatbrauerei in allen
schönen guten abend
guten abend auch von meiner seite aus
klar vielleicht mit ihnen in pinneberg
einmal beginnen kosmetikerin habe ich
gerade schon gesagt vielleicht
beschreiben sie den finanzminister
einmal ganz kurz ihre lage im moment im
kaugummi lockdown also für uns ist es
sehr schwierig jetzt noch auf den beinen
zu bleiben es geht um unsere existenz
und um arbeitsplätze
ich weiß nicht ob sie wissen herr scholz
aber wir haben auch vor der pandemie mit
extremen gene vorlagen gearbeitet
das heißt mit handschuh mit masken und
deswegen kann ich es nicht verstehen
warum die friseure jetzt öffnen dürfen
und wir nicht das heißt ihre ganz
konkrete erwartungen an den mittwoch ist
ganz einfach machen sie ist halt auch
für uns wieder auf richtig richtig dass
wir wieder
öffnen können weil wir haben immer mit
hygienevorschriften gearbeitet gehabt
deswegen kann ich es überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen warum die friseure jetzt
öffnen dürfen und wir nicht weil sie ja
auch gegenmaßnahmen geschult ist ja klar
dass mit diesem zuletzt vereinbarten
ersten schritt die friseure eben wieder
zu öffnen dann sofort auch die fragen
kommen in ihrem bereich es ist aber
besonders nachvollziehbar frau kosor was
sagt der bundesfinanzminister der
vizekanzler dazu r stolz dass man sagt
münch die die sind es gewohnt mit diesen
hygienemaßnahmen zu arbeiten mit
handschuhen und so weiter und so fort da
geht es besonders hygienisch zu anders
als im einzelhandel vielleicht und die
sind fertig die könnten sofort öffnen
zunächst einmal habe ich mir die
situation schon letzte woche noch mal
sehr sorgfältig schildern lassen ich
habe mit sehr vielen kosmetikerin und
friseurinnen und friseuren in
brandenburg gesprochen die mir
eigentlich die gleiche situation
geschildert haben und auch das gleiche
ansinnen das will ich dazu sagen weil es
ja doch für uns alle so ist dass wir in
dem augenblick in dem wir einen öffnung
schritt machen sofort die debatte
bekommen und warum nicht wir
das darf uns das war jetzt nicht dazu
verführen dass wir gar nichts uns trauen
nach dem motto wir kriegen das hinterher
gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen deshalb
ist es wichtig dass wir eine strategie
beschreiben in der die mehreren schritte
auch dabei sind und ganz sicher ist das
was wir eben gehört haben etwas das
nicht ungehört verhallen bleibt wird
wenn ich das mal so abstrakt wie müller
das ist also das heißt sie würden sich
trauen frau kosor zumindest zu sagen der
mittwoch das wird kein ganz schlechter
tag wieder die frage was geschieht zum
beispiel mit mit kosmetikstudios wird
auch eine entscheidung getroffen ich
will da nicht vorgreifen
obwohl das für mich leicht wäre die eine
oder andere treffsichere prognose zu
machen die den sound nehmen waren wir
mit also das haben japanische mutter tag
für sie frau kosor also das problem
scheint mir an diesem tisch schon mal in
teilen erstmal gelöst ja auch wenn das
geschäft vielleicht nicht ganz so
anspringt wie das normal war ohne corona
und so weiter aber es geht zumindest
wieder los das interpretiere ich jetzt
einfach mal ganz fläche rainer scholz
sprechen wir mit tatjana steinbrenner
ich habe schon gerade gesagt kaufhaus
chefin
haben auch sie die hoffnung mit blick
auf den mittwoch dass es herr scholz hat
gerade schon das problem oder die
herausforderung mit den tests
angesprochen dass bei ihnen in dem einen
im einzelhandel in ihrer branche sich
richtig was tun könnte am mittwoch
also ich wünsche es mir weil nur eine
perspektive das wäre für uns nicht gut
wir brauchen eine öffnung und zwar eine
richtige öffnung nicht wieder einer auf
800 quadratmeter reduzierte öffnung oder
vielleicht einfamilienhaus stand wir
haben hier knapp 5000 quadratmeter
die dann eine viertelstunde ein zeitloch
buchen kann und danach eine
viertelstunde gelüftet werden müsste das
sind einfach nicht praktikable ansätze
ich brauche eine ganz normale öffnung
und ich möchte gerne wieder
unternehmerin sein
geben sie uns bitte wieder die
verantwortung zurück weil ich glaube als
verantwortungsvolle unternehmerin würde
ich es niemals riskieren dass ich meine
mitarbeiter meine kunden nun auch mich
selber in einem risiko stützen würde ich
glaube es wird wieder zeit dass ich
wieder verantwortungsvoll handeln kann
also frau stein bei der will vor allen
dingen eins von ihnen herr scholz sie
will das gestalten können die will
verantwortung das wollen ganz viele das
ist ja auch toll
übrigens auch für mich sehr
beeindruckend zu sehen wie viel elan in
unserer gesellschaft ist und das große
problem mit dem wir alle umgehen müssen
ist das war ja auch schon vor dem
zweiten lockdown so als wir dann solche
beschränkung gemacht haben das
unglaublich viele alles richtig gemacht
haben
trotzdem sind die zahlen explodiert und
das ist ja etwas was wir auch nicht
hinnehmen können deshalb will ich sehr
klar sagen die öffnungs schritte werde
jetzt diskutiert wird und wo es jede
stunde hin und her geht nach den
debatten die ich jedenfalls mit vielen
führe die aber ganz ernsthaft und in
genau wissen um die wirtschaftlichen
probleme zum beispiel eines solchen
kaufhauses geredet wird diese diskussion
geht schon darum dass man präzise
öffnungs schritte beschreibt so dass
jeder weiß woran da ist das ist glaube
ich das allerwichtigste das schlimmste
wäre doch wenn man ein gefühl hat auch
jetzt haben sie wieder nicht gesagt wie
es lang geht obwohl das eigentlich schon
gemeint war
und wenn sich so ein eindruck festival
uns eigentlich nur
von termin zu termin der eindruck
entstanden und dann nichts zu machen
sondern es geht ja immer um gesundheit
und leben das darf niemand vergessen und
die unfähigkeit sich zu einigen
das muss man so ähnlich schon ist unser
glaube ich jetzt ausreichend da ich
jedenfalls will mal die vorhersage
machen dass wir es schon schaffen werden
am mittwoch diese perspektive irgendwie
zu beschreiben und zwar so dass man sich
da so frau steiner rennen reist nach dem
mittwoch wann sie ihr kaufhaus wieder
öffnen kann und wie also die wege werden
beschrieben werden ob da jeweils ein
ganz klares datum oder die kriterien für
benannt sind das ist etwas über das noch
diskutiert wird aber so dass man sich
schon mal darauf vorbereiten kann und
weiß was da gemeint ist und wie das
funktioniert ich will das ausdrücklich
sagen das kann nicht alles in einem
schritt erfolgen
das würde nicht funktionieren das ist
auch nicht nicht klug und logisch denn
wir haben ja auch vorher festgestellt
dass obwohl es millionen unternehmen gab
die alles richtig gemacht habt was
erwartet und deutschland ich glaube
jetzt hatte der plan von johnson auch in
großbritannien gezeigt das ist gar nicht
die erwartung der menschen dass jetzt
auf einen schlag alles wieder öffnet ich
glaube dass er so viel hat man den
vergangenen monaten verstanden dass das
nicht besonders klug wäre ich möchte
noch mal bei einem punkt bleiben den
frau steinbach in der gerade
angesprochen hat nämlich die s shoppen
auf einzeltermine ich habe mich heute
nachmittag mit dem thalia chef auch
darüber unterhalten wird michael busch
und habe ihn gefragt ob dieses click and
needs dieses shoppen mit vereinbarten
termin
ob er das wirklich für praktikabel und
sinnvoll hält was immer im moment
passiert ist
dass man den eindruck hat dass die
politik gar nicht genau weiß was in
unternehmen und was insbesondere bei
händlern eigentlich passiert in folge
ihre entscheidungen und das was sie
gerade angesprochen haben click and meet
was ihr in den letzten tagen seitens der
politik wie die sau durchs dorf
getrieben wird das ein
schildbürgerstreich
er wird nach
auffassung aller händler mit denen ich
gesprochen habe wird es eher zu einer
erhöhung des verlustes als vor einer
entlastung führen
das ist weder strategie noch ist das
perspektive und was wir als händler und
was auch ich persönlich von olaf scholz
von malu dreyer von der gesamten spd von
der politik was wir erwarten ist führung
und ein klares bekenntnis zur öffnung
des handels am 8
denn ich möchte nicht irgendwann in
unseren innenstädten erleben und ich
mach das mal rheinland pfalz fest dass
ludwigshafen zu liverpool oder mainz zu
manchester wird und es dort genauso
traurig aussieht denn wegsperren allein
kann doch hier nicht die lösung sein
also der chef der buchhandelskette
thalia sagt das ist ein
schildbürgerstreich wenn man über dieses
klicken mit über dieses shoppen mit
einzeltermine überhaupt spricht das
würde nicht funktionieren wie stehen sie
dazu
das ist nicht die lösung ob es ein
zwischenschritt ist darüber wird gerade
intensiv miteinander diskutiert aber
wirtschaftliche verluste vermeiden kann
man nicht dadurch dass wir clique
mitmachen oder was auch immer
sondern das wird erst dann erfolgreich
gelingen wenn wir wird nicht die öffnung
zustande bringen und deshalb noch mal
müssen wir eine schrittfolge festlegen
da wird nicht alles am 8 erfolgen ich
habe es schon gesagt das kann auch nicht
funktionieren
und diese schrittfolge muss so sein das
wir uns alle gemeinsam sicher sind dass
wir das nicht wieder zurücknehmen müssen
ich will noch mal konkret bei frau
steinbrenner bleiben und bei öffnung
schritten für den einzelhandel sie haben
eigene der alten liegen wenn ich doch
sagen darf dass führung hier gefragt ist
sehr berechtigt das trifft aber auch sie
unbedingt das war jetzt nicht so dass er
gesagt hat also bis auf ich schon sagen
uns bisher super eine art führung
bestellt ich wollte nur sagen wird
gemacht frau steinbrenner sie hatten
einerseits das mit den einzelterminen
angesprochen gleichzeitig kamen von
herrn scholz vehement die forderung oder
beziehungsweise auch das versprechen das
durchzusetzen mit vermehrten test mit
einer klaren test strategie eben diese
öffnung schritte durchsetzen zu können
können sie sich das in der praxis schon
ausmalen wie das aussehen könnte bei
mit testung vor ihrem kaufhaus ja also
aus x men ist mir ehrlich gesagt gar
nicht weil das von der umsetzung total
schwierig ist ich meine anderen es gibt
ja schon städte die das machen die an
zentralen punkten tests anbieten wie zum
beispiel in tübingen
so was kann ich mir vorstellen aber ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen bei den vielen
kunden die hier täglich hoffentlich
irgendwann mal wieder rein kommen also
es wird auch da muss man auch
realistisch sein am anfang nicht wieder
dieser kundenstrom sein wie man es
gewohnt ist die leute sind wahnsinnig
verängstigt ich muss meinen kunden
wieder das vertrauen geben aber dass sie
dann erst mal bei mir vor der tür stehen
müssen um getestet zu werden um danach
dann eine bild zeitung zu kaufen das ist
in der realität für uns nicht umsetzbar
aber eine zentrale teststation kommunal
zum beispiel das kann ich mir gut
vorstellen
herr scholz haben sie das in der praxis
schon mal durchdacht also das falscheste
wäre jetzt an der stelle erst mal gleich
zu sagen ja funktioniert sowieso wieder
nicht das klingt ja erstmal nach einer
guten idee nach einem weg den wird
möglicherweise viel früher hätten
bestreiten können dass man wirklich
regelmäßig getestet wird und dass eben
auch in der einkaufsstraße machen können
haben sie einmal durchdacht wie das
praktisch funktionieren kann
nicht nur ich auch viele andere deshalb
kenne ich auch den einwand schon sehr
genau den wir eben gehört haben und den
ich auch nachvollziehen kann
dann sind die meisten der meinung so die
idee vor jedem geschäft wird jetzt ein
selbsttest stationen eingerichtet und da
muss man erst mal durch und kommt dann
ein paar minuten später weiter und geht
in den laden rein ist vielleicht nicht
so gut organisiert war
ob es dann möglich ist das zum beispiel
der handel auch selber testzentren
organisierten den einkaufs auch gegnern
nur sagt hier kann das funktionieren
es ist eine frage die mit erörtert wird
hier könnt ihr das vermutlich besser als
der staat wenn ich das mal so bösartig
sagen kann es ist also eher bösartig
wenn ich das sagen darf aber trotzdem
aber stimmen trotzdem weiß ich auch
nicht das mal so mal so die einkommen
mal was die anderen auch aber um jetzt
ganz konkret zu sagen die frage dass das
etwas kompliziert sein könnten wenn man
die leute wirklich sich vor den häusern
anstellen lässt die ist schon angekommen
und deshalb ist es ein völlig
berechtigter einwand was das aber für
konsequenzen für den eröffnungstag
also wann der richtige ist und wie man
das drumherum organisiert und wo testen
ich habe es vorhin gesagt eine rolle
spielt und wo vielleicht nicht so sehr
das ist ein großes thema auch die frage
wo kriege ich denn eigentlich eine
sicher bescheinigte zettel dass ich mich
heute habt testen lassen das muss dann
ja wenigstens den tag über gelten und
das ist alles ja im test nicht ganz
einfachen beispielen im testzentrum vor
dem einkaufszentrum im testzentrum am
kudamm oder auf der mönckebergstraße die
einzelhandelsverbände haben signalisiert
dass sie das auch nicht für super
perfekt hand halten und auch nicht
organisieren möchten auch das wird jetzt
gerade diskutiert was das denn bedeutet
das klingt nach name ziemlich weiten weg
als ich es natürlich gleich so er gerade
so ein bisschen euphorisch zu anfang der
saisoneröffnungs perspektivisch bleiben
dass wir mit dass wir am dritten eine
entscheidung treffen ja sicher das ist
ja auch notwendig aber all diese fragen
müssten bedacht werden und das zeigt ja
auch richtig das ist hier keine
schnellschüsse zu machen sondern genau
all diese dinge bis zum letzten ende
durchzuspielen damit es auch
funktioniert der britische premier
johnson hat es ja geschafft mit seinem
öffnungs plan erst mal so eine euphorie
auszulösen weil er ganz präzise benannt
hat erstmal was wann passiert werden sie
so präzise sein wie johnson oder nicht
so präzise wir können glaube ich alle
gemeinsam sagen dass wir im sommer
wieder mehr möglichkeiten haben weil das
empfinden wir haben uns angeschrieben
und ich glaube dass wir angesichts der
infektionszahlen die wir haben und
angesichts der tatsache dass wir einen
schritt planen entwickeln müssen nicht
hinter jede entscheidung ein festes
datum setzen können aber es muss klar
sein dass es auf öffnung hin zielt und
dass wir sehen dass wir so schnell wie
möglich so viele geimpft haben dass wir
daraus dann die nächsten schritte ab
bleibt also nicht so präzise wie johnson
die haben ja schon eine riesige noch
seien nur anders präzise schlechter als
die briten leider wir machen noch mal
weiter mit niklas seitler der
netterweise lange gewartet hat in der
ich grüße sie hat södler sie sind chef
einer tradition privatbrauerei welche
hoffnung machen sie sich mit blick auf
den mittwoch und das treffen auch mit
dem vizekanzler genau einen
wunderschönen guten abend wenn die runde
sehr geehrter scholz ich glaube die
größten anliegen von der brauindustrie
wären zum einen dass eine klare
bestätigung kommt dass das dass ich fix
kostenerstattung sämtliche ware eben
auch auf das fast wie ausgeweitet wird
und somit von uns brauereien dass ihr
was wir nicht verkaufen können erstattet
bekommen weil wir haben es unverschuldet
nicht verkaufen können und die zwei
anderen forderungen die ich hätte mir
ganz wichtig am herzen liegen sind
anforderungen für unsere kunden aus der
hotellerie und gastronomie
wir brauchen hier ganz ganz ganz
dringend einfach eine perspektive klare
aussagen vielleicht auch runtergebrochen
auf unterschiedliche arten von
gastgebern
es gibt ja auch ferienwohnungen nicht
nur große hotels speziell bei uns im
allgäu vielleicht kann man da auch mit
unterschiedlichem maß messen die zeit
wäre ja um es gut vorzubereiten und das
weitere wäre dann noch die letzte
forderung dass wir in der gastronomie
und hotellerie die mehrwertsteuer
dauerhaft senken und auch auf getränke
ausweiten wenn sie können mir glauben es
sind viele von unseren kunden und
schuldet quasi in die verschuldung
wieder herein geraten und die brauchen
bringen
hoffnungsschimmer und auch eine
möglichkeit wie sie nach der pandemie
die schulden wieder abarbeiten herzner
drei forderungen dann gehen wir die der
reihe nach durch oder von hinten erstmal
die mehrwertsteuersenkung das wollen sie
da haben sie schon gedacht dass ziehen
sie weiter durch das leiten wir glauben
dauerhaft an dem fristet die
mehrwertsteuersenkung die wir da gemacht
haben wird jetzt verlängert zumindest
bis zur bundestagswahl rein das g11 auch
länger das ist auch länger das wird ein
gesetz geben das ist jetzt das haben wir
schon auf den weg gebracht das wird
jetzt passieren mit dem ergebnis dass
die mehrwertsteuersenkung die befristet
war bis zur mitte des jahres dauerhaft
erfolg haben dran anforderung nummer
drei forderung nummer zwei war die
perspektive einmal an
bei den einzelhandel gesprochen aber
nicht über die gastronomie sie haben so
ein bisschen gesagt im sommer ja ja
jetzt sagt hettler auch hotels sind ja
auch noch dran wir alle gucken so ein
bisschen auf ostern hat er schon
deutlich wenn es nach den vorstellungen
des einen oder der anderen ginge dann
wäre das so am 8 alles auf und das geht
alles schief deshalb werden wir eine
schritt für schritt folge beschreiben
müssen aber da müssen hotels und
gastronomie auch benannt sein
niemandem darf das gefühl haben dass man
noch nicht mal sein problem erörtert hat
und nicht beschrieben hat wann denn
welche möglichkeiten entstehen diese
klarheit muss da ein rein und das finde
ich kann auch jeder bürger und jede
bürgerin gibt im moment doch gute
argumente händler zu sagen dass zum
beispiel die außengastronomie keine
perspektive bekommen kein klar was da
alles bekommt damit die außengastronomie
muss eine perspektive bekommen
perspektive heißt aber dass wir genau
beschreiben wanderers erfolgt und wie
wir das machen darüber wird jetzt gab
noch geredet aber es muss so sein dass
man sich daran festhalten kann und immer
kleine fussnote wenn alles explodiert
das erstellte jeder das versteht jeder
und erste forderung war das herz oder
entschädigt wird für das was er hinter
sich nicht verkaufen konnte weil er lebt
natürlich von dem biergarten verkauf und
nicht von der nicht von der
flaschenabfüllung im supermarkt er hat
das ganze zeug wegschütten müssen das
ganze zeug verzeihen sie als guter hier
ich habe neulich mit einem brauer
gesprochen der dann daraus eine kleine
tugend gemacht hat aus dieser not und
jetzt bier retter flaschen verteilt hat
das ist das fass bier das er dann
schnell verteilt hat und versucht hat
verkaufen zu lassen
aber ja er kann nicht einmal machen er
kann nicht darüber nach was händler ist
es am ende hat sich das vor dass er
dafür eine entschädigung bekommen
der vermieter hat eine klare antwort
trotzdem war ich nur sagen das habe ich
konkret als erfahrung gemacht dass heißt
das problem ist wirklich überall da und
wir haben jetzt auch uns verständigt
an diesem freitag dass wir eine lösung
organisieren die lautet dass wir das
fass bier als kosten absetzbar
ok also was ist klare antwort an diese
wunde danke erzähler danke frau stein
bringen
und danke frau koller nach pinneberg und
wir schauen noch einmal auf das thema
reisen was auch besprochen werden wird
am mittwoch weiß ich denn eigentlich
nächsten mittwoch wann oder ob ich den
sommerurlaub planen kann
das finde ich schwer vorherzusagen aber
es ist eine frage die man bald klären
muss ich persönlich glaube dass man sich
da schon hoffnungen machen kann also wir
sind ja es sind ja zig-millionen geimpft
im sommer und das kann ja nicht
konsequenzen los bleiben ältere menschen
und pflegepersonal lehrer und
lehrerinnen hoffentlich erzieher und
erzieherisch rechne immer in den
millionen dosen die uns gegenwärtig so
angekündigt worden sind von den verkehr
dass die razzia durch die familien also
da eine sehr sehr viele millionen dosen
und was wir hoffen dürfen ist doch dass
wir damit einen effekt haben auch auf
das infektionsgeschehen war erstens
diejenigen geimpft sind können nicht
mehr angestellt werden aber zumindest
während sich ja die botschaften die
lauten dass die infektiosität auch
nachlässen und man gewissermaßen wenige
andere ansteckt so dass wenn erst mal
ganz viele geimpft sind das auch dazu
führt dass die infektionszahlen
insgesamt so also wären impfpass hat der
kann dann reisen darf er den stempel hat
eine debatte die jetzt in ganz europa
geführt hat über das thema jetzt wird
erstmal ein gemeinsamer im fass
hergestellt und es war eine sehr kluge
entscheidung die konsequenzen die daraus
abzuleiten sind nicht gleich mit der
technik entscheidung zu verbinden
ich glaube dass wir uns darüber gedanken
machen müssen aber zur richtigen zeit
weil ich das gefühl habe dass wir da
eine ja ich wie soll ich das so eine
schimäre nachjagen es kann sein dass wir
uns von beschränkungen befreien lassen
wollen
zu einem zeitpunkt wo wir viele
beschränkungen sowieso aufheben weil das
infektion erklärt und so an und alle ist
und die fragen und genügend geimpft sind
ich werde deswegen bisschen geduld weil
die ungeduldig weil die frage ja doch
sehr konkret ist wenn man nämlich nur
überlegt was passiert jetzt mit dem
sommerurlaub ich glaube da ist
manja man wersauer wenn einem sie sagen
würden oder die kanzler und sagen würde
würd mich diesen sommer eher wer
verdammt schade aber man wüsste dann
woran man ist man weiß es aber einfach
nicht und würde so gern wissen und der
johnson geht daher und sagt geht im
sommer unter den bedingungen und dann
gehen die buchung losgehen haben sie bei
tui die die läden eingelaufen in
großbritannien und haben die buchung
gemacht und haben auf mallorca schon mal
die handtücher hingelegt sehr gut habe
haben sie auch alles schon gefilmt
obwohl sie noch gar nicht da liegen aber
jedenfalls die konkrete aussage ist das
muss dazu sehr bald eine aussage geben
weil man möchte das ja nicht ein genau
woher buchen genau und deshalb sage ich
ich glaube dass wir hoffen können dass
im sommer mehr möglich ist auch was
diese frage betrifft einfach weil wir so
weit gekommen sein werden mit den
impfungen dass es schon mit dem teufel
zugehen müsste wenn wir dann nicht an
völlig an viel besser kontrollierbares
entwicklung stehen oder gar nicht warum
sie es nicht einfach entscheiden das
verstehe ich an der stelle gar nicht
weil wie gesagt der johnson macht auch
der entscheidet auch sie könnten doch
auch den deutschen sagen nicht dass alle
reisen dürfen aber unter welchen
bedingungen welche voraussetzungen
erfüllt werden müssten das kann man doch
jetzt machen es ist ja gar nicht mehr so
lange schon dass wir diesem fall ist
deutschland der 16 länder und die
bundesregierung entscheidungen treffen
können und auch müssen die auch diese
fragen stück für stück mit bewegen da
bin ich völlig einer meinung und auch
nicht in allzu ferner zeit es muss klare
ansagen über dieses thema geben und sie
können sich sicher sein dass ich aus
meiner haut nicht mehr aus meiner haut
raus komme ich werde schon entscheidung
treffen
das nehmen wir mit und schauen einmal wo
wir so viel jetzt oder ich so viel über
johnson gesprochen haben einmal nach
großbritannien und auch nach israel
nämlich zu meinen kolleginnen dem bild
reporterin sara winczewski in london und
zu julia winczewski in london und zu
sarah fantl nach jerusalem euch beiden
schönen guten abend und mit london
wollen wir einmal angucken anfangen
frau winczewski ich habe gerade schon
gesagt wir gucken mit etwas neid nach
london nach großbritannien und wie
schauen die briten auf uns schauen die
mit ein bisschen häme mit ein bisschen
schadenfreude nach deutschland hallo
kann nach berlin ja ich meine die briten
das muss man sagen die sind so von der
stimmung her soll nicht gut gelaunt wie
das wetter hier gestern in london war
natürlich gibt es hier jetzt wirklich
grund zu feiern boris johnson hat letzte
woche eindeutige daten verkündet und das
gibt dem briten hoffnung weil hier das
leben wirklich nun langsam aber sicher
zur normalität zurückkehren kann
unter anderem eines der kidaid sozusagen
der zwölfte april
ich stehe hier in einem pub von ryan
robbins hackney church flug dieser park
darf ab zwölften april wieder öffnen für
die außenbewirtung das heißt das ist
jetzt eine der ganz großen thematiken wo
die engländer ist sich natürlich freuen
um endlich wieder ihre fans zu trinken
mit freunden draußen in der
außenbewirtung und wir reden jetzt hier
mit ryan robbins um zu hören wie er sich
auf diesen großen tag den zwölften april
vorbereitet es vielleicht einfach kurz
sagen wie sie sich darauf vorbereiten
dass sie zum 9 normal zurückkehren
können uns helfen ja am zwölften april
da bereiten wir unsere außenbereiche
jetzt schon vor
und wir sind natürlich dann auch
ausgestattet mit hygieneartikeln und
desinfektionsmitteln es gibt
entsprechende regulatorien und wir
hoffen dass wir dann tatsächlich mit
einer sicheren umgebung für alle hier
wieder öffnen können und wir werden
frisches bier am start
das ist natürlich sehr wichtig und wie
sind sie mit dem lockdown umgegangen wie
war es für sie hier im heck niedriger
ich glaube es war sehr schwer für alle
beteiligten
das war wirklich ein sehr harter
lockdown und das war für geschäfte sehr
schwierig viele haben zu hause arbeiten
können hier natürlich nicht wir haben
versucht die besten lösungen ausfindig
zu machen
wir haben web shops entwickelt wir haben
dann mit click & collect gearbeitet wir
haben aber auch liefer systeme gehabt um
dann unser bier beispielsweise in
flaschen oder dosen verkaufen zu können
in den verschiedenen lockt downs haben
wir auch verschiedene einschränkungen
erlebt aber wir haben versucht auch
beispielsweise unsere fans auf der
straße zu verkaufen oder andere
möglichkeiten auf zypern ja wann darf
ich kurz fragen welchen rat würden sie
den menschen in deutschland geben sie
haben ja offensichtlich das
erfolgsrezept für um die großbritannien
die situation in großbritannien jetzt
schon für sich entwickelt wir werden
jetzt damit zwölfter april eröffnen und
ich sehe auch wie eben das impfprogramm
hier fortschritte macht und das gibt uns
allen zuversicht und für uns war die
erfahrung so dass wir selbst mit den
lockt bei uns eigentlich gut
zurechtgekommen sind wir haben dann
zunächst auch mal noch die möglichkeit
gehabt beispielsweise draußen
auszuschenken aber jetzt wird eben mit
dem impfprogramm es wohl zuversichtlich
so aussehen dass wird wieder aufmachen
können das ist also wirklich ein gutes
vorbild auch für deutschland vielen dank
rhein deutschland danke julia winczewski
nach london und die gehen weiter nach
jerusalem zu sarah fantl und auch da
geht wieder immer mehr normales leben
sarah ja wie man hinter gesehen kann es
gibt seit diesem wochenende sogar schon
wieder konzerte für menschen mit einem
grünen pass den man dann so auf seinem
handy mit sich herumträgt mit einem qr
code also das ist die hoffnung wie viele
nutzen das denn schon bei dir in
jerusalem sarah also über drei millionen
menschen haben bereits ihre zweite
impfdosis bekommen das sind 30 prozent
des landes und über 50 prozent haben
schon die erste dosis bekommen
danke sarah nach jerusalem scholz das
ist die hoffnung das sind die bilder der
hoffnung einmal aus london gut pub ist
noch leer aber der weiß zumindest man
darauf machen kann und dann ganz konkret
drei millionen menschen die mit diesem
impfpass auf dem handy digital halt
wieder auf veranstaltungen können wir
haben aber auch gehört die voraussetzung
50 prozent der
bürgerinnen und bürger israels sind
schon geimpft und das ist ja ein
unterschied zu unserer situation ja sehr
früh habe ich ja auf das thema
hingewiesen dass wir die frage ob europa
genügend impfstoff beschafft hat doch
mal kritisch bewerten müssen jetzt sind
wir unterwegs all das zu tun was möglich
ist aber es kommt jetzt ja voran wir
haben unglaublich viele gute impfstoffe
die von bayern und moderner es kommt
demnächst auch der von coeur weg um die
modernen impfstoffe zu nehmen aber auch
die klassische gestellten sind hoch
wirksam und effizient und stehen in
großer zahl zur verfügung und mit dem
fortschreiten des impfens werden wir
auch solche entscheidungen treffen
können und auch entscheidung zur öffnung
treffen können und ähnlicher weise
diesen optimismus den würde ich auch
gerne hier hinterlassen
deshalb rede ich immer darüber das geht
doch jetzt in die richtige richtung wir
müssen versuchen das jetzt noch
umzusteuern in dieser zeit damit die
sachen nicht schief laufen aber wir
müssen die möglichkeiten auch nutzen die
wir haben also unser impfen wird jetzt
erstmal auch das testen da liegt ganz
viel hoffnung auf oder wird das auch ein
desaster da geht es ja auch um
beschaffen und hier geht es auch um
verteilung da gibt es auch im logistik
deshalb bin ich dafür dass man das gut
vorbereitet und finde richtig dass wir
gesagt haben wir entscheiden das
zusammen mit den ministerpräsidentinnen
und ministerpräsidenten welche tests
strategie wir einsetzen denn das muss ja
mit der öffnung strategie zusammen
passen wäre das nicht eine idee dass der
industrie dass den unternehmen zu
überlassen die tests so schnell wie
möglich dahin zu bringen wo sie
gebraucht werden zum beispiel wäre in
der dhl so wäre es ja sowieso also die
frage wie das dahin kommt das wird sie
schon organisieren lassen aber wenn wir
zum beispiel sagen was ich richtig finde
die unternehmen sollen ihre
beschäftigten testen und diese
möglichkeit nutzen dann werden die ihre
logistiker selbst organisieren und das
ja auch selber finanzieren wenn wir das
nutzen für kitas und schulen in
irgendeinem umfang den wir noch genau
festlegen müssen dann ist das etwas was
eine andere organisation erfordert und
wenn wir überall auch noch testzentren
haben wo man hingehen kann einfach so
weil man sagt ich möchte mich testen
lassen dann ist das der dritte weg deren
organisiert werden muss mit blick auf
diesen mittwoch würde ich gern noch
einmal abrunden also wir legen ganz viel
hoffnung in dieses testen
eröffnungs schritte zu glauben sie haben
auch gesagt es gibt eine große
bandbreite dann bei der inzidenz und das
dass man also mehr toleranz hat bei der
inzidenz österreich hat das ja genauso
gemacht ist diesen weg gegangen aber wie
viel toleranz also wann sagt man wieder
oh jetzt müssen wir wieder zurückdrehen
diese grenze muss ist ja auch geben muss
es geben und über die sollten wir uns
lieber jetzt verständigen weil es ja
eigentlich nur um eins geht nämlich dass
die zahlen nicht wieder explodieren
solange wir das ganze im griff haben und
dass ein bisschen schwankt ist das
vielleicht nicht so dramatisch aber in
dem augenblick als ich sie helfen sie
dürfen entschuldigung wenn ich noch mal
das wort weil die dürfen erst mal ein
bisschen hochgeht dass die dürfen
schwanken und dann gibt es eben
schwanken geht einmal rauf und runter so
ist das mit dem aber eben auch mal drauf
aber die das entscheidende ist dass man
aber sich klar ist dass das nicht
bedeuten kann dass wir akzeptieren dass
die infektionszahlen wieder dramatisch
steigen nicht dramatisch aber sie dürfen
etwas drauf gehen das ist ja eine ganz
wichtige nachricht weil bisher weil
genau das nicht erlaubt wir haben immer
nur gehört die zahlen müssen runter
runter runter die müssen auch fünf
wissen ehe sie müssen auf 35 runter
runter wo sein müssen auch runter wegen
unserer aller gesundheit und unsere
liebsten wegen der vielen menschen die
auch leider an corona schon gestorben
sind das sind über 60.000 das ist ja
alle mit musik aus der öffnung will ich
ausdrücklich sagen schwanken ist das
richtige wort wenn sie ein bisschen
banken dann ist das etwas das wir mit
einer test strategie verknüpft
möglicherweise gut hinkriegen können
zahlen dürfen schwanken das nehmen wir
mit und schauen noch einmal auf den auch
von ihnen in den vergangenen wochen so
viel kritisierten
bundesgesundheitsminister vor allen
dingen mit blick auf das impfen so viel
kritisiert nun gab es neuen ärger zum
wochenende um den
bundesgesundheitsminister auch deswegen
weil er natürlich zu denen gehörte die
immer wahlamt am meisten gewarnt haben
und gemahnt haben und dann eben doch zu
einräumen mussten dass sie an einem
solchen tag an dem sie ganz besonders
gewarnt haben ein eigenes dinge eine
ganz eigene veranstaltung hatten
es ist eine dieser eindringlichen
warnungen des bundesgesundheitsminister
keine unnötigen kontakte bitte zu hause
bleiben
wir wissen vor allem wo es die haupt
ansteckungskette gibt nämlich beim
feiern beim gesellig sein zuhause privat
oder eben in der veranstaltung auf der
party im club keine geselligkeit
möglichst zu hause bleiben
die entspannung am zwanzigsten oktober
in einer zeit in der die korona zahlen
drastisch steigen und deutschland vor
dem nächsten schweren lockdown steht
morgens die warnung abends ein dinner in
leipzig rinderfilet und rotwein mit
einem dutzend geladener gäste dazu
vorspann extra 200 kilometer für
geselligkeit in zeiten in denen die
deutschen nicht gesellig sein soll
mit gästen die für diese geselligkeit
zahlen spenden für den wahlkreis des
gesundheitsministers 9.999 euro pro
person für diesen geselligen abend mit
dem corona minister der sich am morgen
danach krank meldet mit corona sein test
positiv 24 stunden nach dieser warnung
wir wissen vor allem wo es die haupt
ansteckung punkte gibt nämlich beim
feiern beim gesellig sein zuhause privat
oder eben in der veranstaltung auf der
party im club
was zeigt ihnen das was ist das für ein
gesundheitsminister der am selben tag
vor geselligkeit warnt und dann am abend
die geselligkeit sucht also ich kenne
das ganze ja auch nur aus den
zeitungsmeldungen und er hat dass der
gesundheitsminister sich dazu jetzt ja
auch geäußert hat insbesondere im
hinblick auf die damals geltenden regeln
aus meiner sicht ist es ganz ganz
wichtig dass wir versuchen wir durch zu
halten in dieser situation und dazu
gehört auch dass man versucht es
möglichst richtig zu machen aber ich
finde jeder von uns vergisst mal das
eine oder andere also das gehört ja auch
dazu ich habe auch mal vergessen von der
regierungsbank bis zum 3 obwohl die fünf
meter die maske aus wie eine ganz andere
dimension dass das ehrt sie dass sie das
jetzt vielleicht noch einmal den
kollegen in der situation bei springen
und vielleicht auch den
es gibt bei uns allen momente bei denen
wir uns nicht 100 prozent an die regeln
halten das ist tatsächlich natürlich so
wir mussten das auch erst mal lernen nur
ist es wenn wir es bei 98 prozent der
fälle machen gibt es zwei jahren immer
wenn man morgens morgen ist diese
mahnung absetzt im zdf morgenmagazin an
diesem 20
oktober und dann fährt man am abend mit
dem auto nach leipzig und trifft sich
dazu dinner das hat eine andere
dimension als wenn man sagt hamann ist
diese fünf meter mehr ohne maske
gelaufen wir verstehen schon das ist
nicht mein stil ist dass ich jetzt hier
da nicht umfassend zu äußern ich finde
der minister hat darauf reagiert und was
dazu gesagt naja es bleibt ohne folgen
ehrlicherweise ich glaube dass das jetzt
nicht angemessen wäre hier jetzt zu
sagen da da da ich glaube es ist richtig
dass er sich geäußert hat und das ist ja
auch in ordnung dass das öffentlich
diskutiert wird das müssen wir alle
aushalten auch wenn wir fehler machen ja
in der tat bei den menschen kommen
nämlich an wasser predigen und wein
trinken und in dem fall stimmt sogar im
grunde genau ich habe in spanien schon
sehr oft erlebt da hat er sich immer an
die regeln gehalten strich drunter und
einmal geblickt auf ihr eigentliches
fach nämlich die staatsfinanzen
herr scholz wird ihnen mulmig im moment
bei dem was sie da so raushauen an
steuergeld es wird mir nicht mulmig aber
ich will ausdrücklich sagen dass es sehr
viel geld ist und dass ich das ganz
genau weiß aber ich weiß was ich tue
wir haben solide gewirtschaftet den
letzten jahren wir hatten 219 eine
situation wo wir alle
stabilitätskriterien europas erfüllt
haben und selbst wenn wir alles geld
jetzt einsetzen dass wir als
kreditbewilligung bekommen haben vom
bundestag im letzten jahr für dieses
jahr für das was vielleicht in der
zukunft noch notwendig sein wird kann
man jetzt schon sagen wir werden am ende
dieser krise weniger schulden haben als
alle g 7 staaten mit denen ich mich okay
so sollte nicht der maßstab sein usa und
japan sollten nicht der maßstab sein
vielleicht können wir einmal die runde
kurz noch erweitern um reiner holznagel
chef des steuerzahlerbundes und olaf
scholz herholz nahe gesagt gerade solide
gewirtschaftet
und wirkt dabei relativ entspannt sind
sie es auch
nein so richtig entspannt mich natürlich
nicht das weiß auch der stolz und ich
sehe die situation schon sehr kritisch
wichtig ist dass wir vor der krise
durchaus gute staatsfinanzen hatten
unsere schulden uhr lief rückwärts das
ist ein novum gewesen insofern war die
ausgangslage sehr gut die schuldenbremse
wurde eingehalten und auch ein
ausgeglichener haushalt sollte für die
folgejahre vorgelegt werden
aber schon damals war der haushalt nicht
hundertprozentig in ordnung jetzt
mussten schon rücklagen angezapft werden
nun haben wir corona und
selbstverständlich muss der staat
reagieren und die hilfspakete sind enorm
wichtig für unsere wirtschaft für unsere
menschen
das ist völlig zu akzeptieren wir müssen
jetzt aufpassen dass auch wirklich
corona hilfen auskommen
viele ausgaben die da beschlossen worden
sind die haben mit corona gar nichts zu
tun
deswegen müssen wir genau hinschauen ob
das was die schuldenbremse jetzt
ermöglicht ist auch tatsächlich hilft
und ich fürchte dass die schulden die
wir jetzt ja nicht immer der vor
der vorwurf war da steht corona hilfe
drauf und ist am ende gar nicht geheuer
hilfe ist was ganz anderes sie nehmen
die schulden auch für das was gar nichts
mit corona zu tun hat also zunächst mal
muss man sich entscheiden was man hier
sagen möchte wir haben gut
gewirtschaftet ist die erste botschaft
darin sind wir uns schon mal einig wir
haben rücklagen erwirtschaftet und ich
habe diese rücklagen bisher gar nicht
eingesetzt weil ich gesagt habe die ist
das gewissermaßen noch ein pulver das
sich trocken halten möchte für alle
fälle die wir in der zukunft haben
werden aber klar ist gegeben sehr viel
geld aus zur stabilisierung der
konjunktur auch damit es nicht plötzlich
einen abbruch gibt wenn wir jetzt sagen
würden die der bau einer geplanten
straße in bayern in niedersachsen in
thüringen findet jetzt nicht statt damit
wir mit unserem geld auskommen obwohl
alles planrecht da ist die bauarbeiter
gewissermaßen schon dastehen und
loslegen wollen und sagen das hat ja
nichts mit corona zu tun wenn wir wegen
der sinkenden staatseinnahmen diese
ausgabe jetzt finanzieren dann ist das
ehrlicherweise volkswirtschaftlich gar
eine ganz gute theorie die richtige ist
wir erhalten jetzt gegen wir sorgen
dafür dass wir ein hohes
investitionsniveau auch in der krise
sie haben damit dass die wirtschaft
stabilisiert weltweit ist das gesagt
worden dass deutschland das geschafft
hat mit diesen maßnahmen und das gleiche
gilt natürlich für die ganzen
hilfsmaßnahmen die übrigens nicht ohne
sind alleine alles zusammen wenn wir
steuer hilfe und wirtschaftshilfen
nehmen sind schon 190 milliarden und da
kommt dann noch die kurzarbeit und
andere genau das wollen wir ihnen einmal
ganz konkret noch mal zeigen sie werden
die zahlen besser kennen noch besser
kennen als er holznagel und ich sowieso
herr scholz wir haben es mal einmal ganz
einfach versucht zu machen auf einem
bierdeckel und haben einmal die ganz
einfache corona rechnung aufgemacht
vielleicht können wir das große einmal
zeigen damit der finanzminister und der
steuerzahlerpräsident auch sehen können
die schulden vor corona das waren rund
1,9 billionen euro und dann tickte wie
holznagel grad schon gesagt hat
plötzlich die uhr die vorher rückwärts
lief dann wieder rauf und es kamen 501
milliarden euro neue schulden ungefähr
dazu so dass der neue schuldenstand bei
2,4 billionen ist wir haben das einmal
runtergerechnet auf den bundesbürger auf
den einwohner das waren vorher ungefähr
22.000 euro was auch schon viel ist
schulden pro kopf und sind jetzt das
macht anschaulich 28 1850 also nummer
prokop 6000 euro dazugekommen und die
frage ist jetzt sehr stolz
wann sie den deckel für uns alle
abbezahlt haben
also das kann ich ihnen gut beantworten
wie wir damit umgehen werden zunächst
mal die usa sind jetzt dabei über 100
prozent staatsverschuldung zu bekommen
wir werden am ende dieser krise knapp
über 70 prozent haben und wieder runter
rutschen auf unter 60 prozent was die
stabilitätskriterien sind wenn wir die
richtigen zukunftsinvestitionen auf den
weg bringen werden wir ende dieses
jahrzehnts anfang der 30er jahre wieder
unter 60 prozent seien alle
stabilitätskriterien erfüllen mit
normalem gutem wachstum das ist das was
uns gelingen kann oder dass das möglich
ist darum geben wir dieses ganze geld
jetzt aus also dieser bierdeckel sie
streben an den ende dieses jahrzehnts
abbezahlt mit dem zurückzahlen der
übermäßigen zusätzlichen kredite sind
weder nach dem grundgesetz verpflichtet
viel früher zu
da steht den gesetzen die wir
beschlossen haben 226 würde bedeuten
meine jüngste tochter sieben jahre alt
kurz bevor sie den führerschein macht
ist die korona rechnung beglichen
holznagel dass sie als tochter wird
diese rechnung nicht begleichen aber sie
wird einen land haben das blüht und ihr
eine hervorragende kommt vergleich nur
in der ersten offenen ehrlichen weil sie
können jetzt dass sie hervorragende
zukunft haben weil wir dafür sorgen dass
wir endlich eine ordentliche gigabit
gesellschaft werden dass das mit der
elektrifizierung klappt das wir moderne
mobilität haben und dass wir zum
beispiel moderne medizin haben wie sie
das jetzt bei direct vorgemacht hat
super nicht ablenken doch mal ganz kurz
bei der rechnung bleiben und an deren
holznagel
das klingt so optimistisch ist er aber
in wahrheit doch ein verdammt langer
zeitraum wenn man sagt ende des
jahrzehnts glauben sie dran ende des
jahrzehnts hat er stolz sein sage ich
jetzt mal seinen bierdeckel bezahlen
also ich hoffe dass die schuldenbremse
wieder eingesetzt wird und dass wir da
nicht beim werkelt man die
schuldenbremse schreibt das zwingend vor
und ab 26 geht's los das der bund
erstmals auch wirklich parlamentarisch
gewollt die schulden zurückgeführt und
ich hoffe dass das eintritt das muss
auch eintreten weil es ist ja auch ein
signal an die finanzmärkte dass
deutschland weiterhin solide
wirtschaftet deswegen da muss er stolz
natürlich wort halten und ich glaube
auch kaum dass ein politiker jetzt sagen
wird die schulden sollen nicht
zurückgezahlt werden aber in der
vergangenheit ist das nie passiert wir
können uns alle noch an die letzte große
wirtschaftskrise ändern 2009/2010 damals
hat der staat auch so richtig in die
vollen gegriffen hat 20 milliarden euro
neue schulden aufgenommen und diese nie
geteilt worden
die sind immer noch da selbst als die
ihn steuertasten quasi durch die decke
ging als wirtschaftswachstum da noch und
nöcher hat niemals anhebung gedacht
deswegen jetzt muss man dranbleiben
jetzt kommt auch belastungstest auch die
politik ein ende auch wort hält und
diese corona schulden teilweise zurück
hätten sie in ihr aktuelles neues
spd-wahlprogramm direkt einschreiben
können eigentlich nur dass sie morgen
vorstellen bin vorher mal durchgegangen
durch das papier konnte bisher den
großen tilgungsplan noch nicht finden
der steht ja in ein bundesgesetz wann
das beginnt mit 226 hab das eben
berichtet für die zusätzlichen schulden
aber ich will auch ganz klar sein wir
sind sehr gut durch diese zeit gekommen
weil wir so ein wachstum stark das land
sind mit vielen arbeitsplätze
und mit einer guten infrastruktur wir
wissen wo das alles verbessert werden
muss das haben wir gerade in dieser
krise noch mal gemerkt wenn es ums
digitale geht zum beispiel und was wir
alles tun müssen aber eins ist ganz klar
wir werden die kraft haben durch
wachstum die das verhältnis von schulden
zu dem zur der wirtschaftsleistung
wieder zu reduzieren und das rückzahlen
gilt ja für einen teil der schulden die
dann mit einem festen zeitplan versehen
sind nochmal die aussage alle leute die
uns jetzt empfehlen das wird nächstes
jahr oder die folgejahre ein rigides
sparprogramm fahren sollen alle
investitionen zurückfahren sollten alles
das was wichtig ist für die zukunft für
die schulen für die digitalisierung die
geben einen falschen rat was die zukunft
deutschlands betrifft wir müssen aus
wachstum heraus die kraft haben mit
diesen schulden fertig zu werden das ist
uns schon öfter gelungen nach der
letzten krise wir waren 219 wieder auf
dem niveau das erste mal seit ewig
langer zeit auf dem niveau das wir
weniger als 60 prozent
staatsverschuldung hatten und da kommen
wir auch wieder hin und die eigentliche
leistung wäre wenn das geld dann auch
bei den von ihnen genannten schulen
endlich ankommt trotzdem die frage von
den holz nadel oder die forderung war
schuldenbremse die bleibt die steht im
grundgesetz und alle müssen sich jetzt
überlegen wie kriegen wir das hin dass
wir unsere aufgaben bewältigen können
dass wir 2022 noch ein krisenjahr haben
das vielleicht nicht das richtige ja ist
um jetzt zu sagen da kommen wir wieder
mit allen mitteln aus die wir haben also
hin und wieder schon lange mit der stadt
fast jeder verstanden ich habe das noch
hab ich gewartet dass es jeder sagt der
cdu vorsitzende hat das gesagt die
haushaltspolitiker haben das gesagt und
in einer ganz und gar holznagel will das
nicht bin mir sicher dass sich ein
bisschen alle werden verstehen
ostarrichi eine harte sparpolitik die
den sozialstaat kaputt macht und die
dafür sorgt dass wir unsere
infrastruktur investitionen müssen wird
nicht als der teufel den mann an die
wand malt und herr heutzutage das heißt
für die sozialleistungen haben ständig
gut ständig ausgeweitet
es wird ja an keiner stelle gespart das
ist doch dass bochum also insofern
gleich von einer harten sparpolitik zu
sprechen ist glaube ich ein wenig zu
viel die eigene
habt ihr alle anderen kollegen
aufgefordert sparpotenziale zu heben
also vielleicht sollte man da noch ein
bisschen energische hingehen und ich
verstehe es auch nicht dass denn immer
beispiele wie schulen heran ist wenn ich
mal die bundeswehr hat mit corona hilfe
jetzt neue munition bekommen ob das
jetzt wirklich ein beitrag in der krise
ich weiß es nicht das kanzleramt soll
verdoppelt werden 600 millionen euro
sollen investiert werden auch
dachbereich vielleicht besser gebraucht
hätte also bleiben dabei
ich glaube das entscheidende ist dass
man dass die zahlen eben nicht abstrakt
bleiben sondern dass man immer im kopf
behält er holznagel unter scholz dass
man denjenigen denen man gerade das
schuljahr genommen hat dass man
denjenigen nicht noch ein riesenklotz an
schulden hinterlässt sondern wirklich
einen klaren wir werden einen
leistungsfähigen volkswirtschaft haben
die aus dieser schulden situation wieder
raus wächst vor allem wenn die richtigen
leute am ruder sind denn das ist eine
frage die der kleine emilian heute hat
auch er blickt mit sorge in dieser
corona zeit und hat zum abschluss dieser
sendung vor allen dingen mit blick auf
den mittwoch auf diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz noch eine
ganz konkrete frage an sie herr chance
das ist und da kaufe ich gerne mal
spielzeuge 1
aber leider hat er jetzt schon seit drei
monaten geschlossen meine freunde und
ich fragen sich scholz dann macht dieser
laden wieder auf ganz konkrete frage dem
rechts nicht mit öffnung strategie zu
antworten muss aber sein es wird an es
wird gesagt wann das wieder geht und das
wird diese mittwoch festgelegt welchen
weg wir beschreiten und wann das möglich
ist so eine entscheidung zu treffen
ja jetzt verstanden ich bin ganz sicher
dass er verstanden hat die zeiten werden
besser und das ist doch so hoffmann
setzen kann
ok ich glaube ich auch verstanden so
irgendwie kann man es noch nicht sagen
ich glaube sowieso war irgendwie die
antwort es gibt uns was andere er sagt
es gibt da ja irgendwie grenzen geben
diese viele politiker die weil sie in
dieser situation keine starke nerven
haben dinge sagen die sie am nächsten
tag wieder zurücknehmen müssen und ich
zähle nicht zu den vielen dank für den
besuch bei bild die richtigen fragen an
olaf scholz heute vizekanzler und
bundesfinanzminister danke für den
besuch
schönen dank
[Musik]